Just then, a
maid came to my room and His
Royal Highness Cecilia
called me. What should I do at this hour? You do
n't have to go. I'll
tell His Highness.
Maybe you're worried about being alone in your room? It's okay.  You
can use the bed. I'm
sorry, this bed is big, so it
's okay for the two of us. So let's do that. Thank you. What do you think
about Prince Cecily
? There's nothing special about him
joining the family's harem.
[Music]
To me.  If you're holding back, it's okay, just tell me the truth.Why did
I bother you so much?If it happened
yesterday, I'll apologize.I'll
learn how to use magic at times like that.I'll study non-official languages ​​and I'll definitely be able to read them.No, no,
no.  That's not it. It's a
misunderstanding. It's not like you got in the way. If
that's the case, then why do you think it's not a bad story? I think it's an honor to be a
member of the royal family. I
think it's lonely, but everyone eventually finds their
own path.  I have to move on
[Music] Let's
go out
[Music]
Good night